welcome to ndsu extension
that's north dakota state university
extension
we provide our programs for everyone
today's program is background in cattle
fall 2021 a series for cattle producers
looking at backgrounding their cattle
today's talk will be feeds alternative
feeds and costs of gain by carl hoppe
extension livestock specialists located
at the carrington research extension
center part of ndsu
our new crop calves in 2021 are on the
ground and are being presently weaned
and the weather has changed and we're
looking forward to a new feeding season
of course that brings challenges so that
um we have to consider what happened
last year and i always have to comment
that our feed prices continue to follow
the corn price
and it might even be higher because of
the drought that we had in 2021 as you
can see in this picture our corn crop
was pretty small and people even turned
cows out on their field just to have
something to eat
and it's been a challenge for us cattle
producers in north dakota but we move on
and i'd just like to go a little walk
through history here
in 2017 our corn prices were actually
less than three dollars a bushel and
that drug the rest of our other feeds
down as well
alfalfa hay was eighty dollars a ton
grass hay was at 65 wheat meds or around
95. uh we had barley malt sprouts at
that time 115 or corn prices around 3
30 a ton the canola mills of 186 a ton
and dry distillers was on par at 113 per
ton all based off the corn price that
was in 2017 and near um
four
years ago
so now uh let's or five years ago now
let's look at what happened in 2018
prices remained almost the same 2019
corn price moved up a little bit maybe
30 40 cents and all the rest of the
feeds increased accordingly in 2020
feed prices remain somewhat the same so
just when you think you've got a trend
going here of years of lower feed costs
for cattle
2021 shows up and our price of corn is
575 a bushel that's because of national
demand not because of the local drought
just because the national demand now
alfalfa hay has increased up to 175
dollars a ton in some places it might be
200 250 a ton depending upon the quality
of the alfalfa um grass say is a 128 125
a ton uh wheat middlings 190 soy hauls
is a new product available in north
dakota because the processing industries
are making it more available and there's
more of them in north
in the north dakota region and it's
being priced at 165.
uh corn silage uh 55 a ton just because
our corn price has gone up canola meal
is surprisingly somewhat constant from
previous years but dry distillers grains
has increased correspondingly just like
the way corn has
so this year our feed costs have
increased
drought makes it a difficult year
and we have been struggling for feed for
cattle producers that were out of feed
they probably sold cows they weaned off
calves early fed them early this
particular program really focuses on the
fall weaning cows the ones that
scraped by with enough feed
worked on their harvest and now that the
weather has changed somewhat in november
weaning is now progressing on these
april mayborn calves
one thing i got to note in north dakota
is that we have a lot of different crop
processing plants across the state
we have
corn distilleries for making ethanol
which creates the byproduct corn
distillate grains
located throughout north dakota as well
as
into south dakota north dakota also has
quite a few wheat mills wheat middling
or wheat mills for making wheat mids
located in grand forks carrington minot
fairmont
i always have to point out that our the
state mill and elevator in grand forks
is the single largest mill in the world
in one location that just underscores
how much wheat mailings are produced on
that plant and mostly shipped out of
state uh we have uh
sugar uh factories uh
processing
across the state
mostly in the red river valley but some
out in sydney montana
these particular
plants produce uh beet pulp usually wet
they can also produce beet tailings but
a lot of that's being now moved up to
grand forks to the ethanol refinery
that's specifically made for uh
fermenting uh the sugars out of beet
tailings and of course we have a couple
of potato processing plants and we have
a wet corn milling facility down at
wahpeton we just have a plethora of
processing co-products available in
north dakota a lot of those are being
shipped out of state but we do have some
local demand and there create an
opportunity for us for cattle feeders in
north dakota
i said earlier here's a description of
what we actually have we got five plants
produced distillers grains we have five
mills to produce wheat mint leaves we've
got one in-state plant that produces soy
hulls
uh we have one plant that produces corn
gluten feed these are all high moderate
protein thirty anywhere from eighteen to
30 protein
soy haul's around 12
and these are all have a highly
fermentable fiber all the starch has
been removed for the most part and
what's left over is fermentable fiber
we do have like i said beet tailings and
beet pulp and we do have a wide variety
of meals available like cannoli meal
linseed meal sunflower meal corn gluten
meal and soybean meal
available for feeds if we need protein
addition to the rations
these are all co-products these are
things that are produced by our plants
of course we have protein sources
on our
that we produce on farm like soybeans or
alfalfa hay
or sunflowers those are all
filled peas and lentils are all play
things that can produce protein as well
as energy on farm and should be
considered in a ration
screenings just a word of screenings be
careful if you're bringing in screenings
from out of state the type of weed seeds
they might have
things like palm or amaranth
could be in those and you can definitely
start a problem on your feed yard
if you're feeding that type of feed
and allowing weeds to grow in the future
let me just make a point here about our
daily nutrient costs i received an email
this morning that talked about
uh how high the protein content was in
his creep feed and wanting to have
exceptional gains in his calves and
while protein's important the most
important part is the energy cost
we spend more in energy costs per day
than we do protein costs it takes energy
preventable fiber starch
even some proteins are metabolized free
energy takes energy to put growth on an
animal
so if we just look at things in general
say that i did some math here it takes
around 14 pounds of edm which is a
measurement of energy content
to uh
put weight gain on a 700 pound steer
uh this would cost about a little over a
dollar a day in pro in energy costs look
at protein costs there would be well
almost a dollar a day however we don't
pay for all the protein we buy the
energy first and then a lot of protein
comes along free for in other words
corn is nine percent protein we buy the
corn for the energy content but we get
nine percent protein basically for free
so we need to do is buy additional
protein to boost up that corn so it has
enough protein to maintain the gain we
want there's a lot of words to say but
really we're feeding that type of ration
we need to provide another six tenths of
a pound of crude protein and if we do
the math cost per pound of protein at 42
cents that means we need to provide an
extra 25 cents
a day in protein costs so it costs a
dollar a day for the energy
and another 25 cents for additional
protein and then of course that pales to
the water cost and be all means that's
water cost per day
please
consider your water quality and water
availability that's some of the cheapest
gain you can have on a in a particular
cowherd
i'd like to look at some math here when
it comes to feed value
we've got four different feed stuffs
canola meal wheat meds corn grain and
distillers grains
um colonel mill is known for its crude
protein at 38 wheat meds is 17 percent
corn is low at eight and a half percent
distillers grains is around 26.6 percent
or almost 30 percent on the dry matter
basis
they all have different energy
calculations
um distillers grains is actually high
since it's got uh some fat in it
more than what corn grain would
and uh the rest of these feeds all are
you know
not considered zany's resources like
corn is there's different costs so we
see canola mill is 255 a ton which
hasn't changed wheat meds are now up to
190 corn grain at 206 and distillers at
230 dollars a ton so if we're looking
cost per pound
our cheapest feed is going to be this
year wheat mids look at cost per pound
of protein our cheapest feed obviously
is canola milk that's what we buy it for
is for its protein but if you look at
cost per pound of energy
our cheapest source again is wheat
middlings although corn and distillate
grains are ranked right in their side by
side as being somewhat competitive
as an energy source that's why distilled
grains is used as high percent a lot of
our rations
please let me talk about feed issues for
fall 2021.
our biggest issue this year is how
drought affected our feeds nitrate
accumulation
has occurred
may have decreased but be sure to test
your speeds for nitrates the forages the
grains you don't need to but the forages
certainly do the co-products probably
don't need to measure those as well but
any forage that you were raised on farm
should be tested for nitrates this year
and if it's over 1500 parts a million
nitrate nitrogen it should be decreased
it should be diluted with other feeds
that are lower nitrate nitrogen
high nitrates can lead to
basically death
and in pregnant cows it can lead to
aborted fetuses so nitrates are not to
be
ignored when it comes to rations be sure
to do a feed test to find out where
yours are at and try to feed under 15 so
the average of the ration delivered to
the cattle is under 1500 parts per
million nitrate nitrogen if you're using
a bell ring then your haze and that bell
ring should certainly be
under that fifteen hundred parts per
million nitrate nitrogen for calves or
otherwise i know some calves prefer to
eat grain and not come over and eat
uh prefer to eat hay and not eat grain
and of course if the nitrate nitrogen
was quite high
and that's all they're eating you would
end up with death loss
so
the other thing a person should do is
sample feeds for feed just for
for doing a feed analysis
a feed test on them
with the drought there's been a very a
lot of variability in the type of feeds
we have out there so
uh feed testing is always important this
year it's a big deal some guys have been
putting up hays or forages that have a
lot of weeds in them try to limit that
to your calves just because intake is
driven by palatability some of these
weeds aren't very palatable and calves
may not eat them of course so
uh our corn seemed to mature for people
that were actually able to get corn
grain that seemed like it was a heavy
test weight so that'll ensure that
there's uh some good energy content in
our corn uh for guys that put up uh corn
silage early because the drought and the
plants just not grown there is a higher
percent water in them so be sure to do a
feed test so you know what type of
moisture content is added so we can
adjust the dry matter uh consumption
accordingly
actually dry matter is going to remain
the same but we'll have to increase the
amount of corn size based on the higher
water content
as i mentioned earlier
our hays are highly variable between
fields when it comes to feed tests so
using book values or even just one test
on one particular load of feed just
really doesn't show what's what could be
out there so there's a lot of
variability out there encourage you to
feed test and know what you have
especially when you're trying to do
rates of gains for calves
our feed costs are quite a bit higher
this year i talked about that earlier
it's 70 percent higher compared to the
last few years
um availability appears to be okay
however
if you're in demand for quite a bit of
feed should probably figure out how to
get that
locked up
some places might need a contract other
places might need money paid for the
contract up front to guarantee supply
but this year
having it on hand might be the best
route to make sure you actually have the
feed
big costs and freight is always an issue
when you're hauling feed around but this
year with the feed transportation
programs available within north dakota
and the usda there might be some subsidy
going on there
or help in paying for the transportation
costs for things bought outside the
normal
grain is high
that's not a localized drought demand
that's a national demand and of course
whenever grain prices go up hey prices
go up as well but when you're in a
drought hey prices because of how
difficult they are to transport long
distances
uh they go up as well so that becomes a
big challenge
on trying to find haze at a reasonable
price for feeding cattle i'd like to go
through some rations now
i've got 12 different rations to discuss
in this particular slide if you look at
these rations we first start off with a
grass hay supplemented with some wheat
mitts we're looking at two pounds a day
gain
um it would take around 13 pounds of
grass hay and supplement seven pounds of
wheat meds and it would cost a dollar 48
per day with a feed cost per pound to
gain at uh 74 cents
now if you want to pick up our gain from
two pounds up to 2.6 pounds we're going
to have to throw in a little alfalfa hay
for the protein and energy and increase
the wheat meds up to 10 percent also we
have to increase the calcium in the
ration and we did that with the alfalfa
a
well our feed costs went up another
extra 20 cents a day because of this
ration
but our feed cost goes down 10 cents per
pound again
now the same thing holds true when we
start looking at using grass hay and
wheat mids at a higher amount at 12
pounds
we're looking at 2.8 pounds per day gain
we have to include the limestone to
offset the high phosphorus content of
wheat mids
and
you'll see that it costs almost the same
as the previous ration with two tenths
of a pound better gain which means our
feed cost per pound of gain actually
went down you'll see this in the next
slides too where feed costs
go down as our
gain increases now remember on this
particular ration we're talking a dollar
66 a day let's look at some other
rations now
here's an alfalfa corn alfalfa hay corn
silage ration you got the king of
forages in in corn sides and the queen
of forages and alfalfa hay they'll blend
to do together at that amount could give
at eight pounds alfalfa hay and 29
pounds of corn size you get 1.8 pounds
per day average daily gain uh it'd cost
you a buck and a half a day but your
feed costs are at 83 cents now if you
have a little corn grain in there and
some wheat meds uh take out the corn
sides you put in alfalfa hay so six
pounds of grass saved four pounds of
alfalfa hey two pounds of corn and eight
pounds of wheat man so give you 2.6
pounds per day gain 65 cent cost to gain
1.69 boy that's very similar to that
other ration that was provided earlier
now if we go with one that looks for a
little bit better average daily gain at
three pounds
um
we'll find out that uh
where you're feeding four pounds of
grass hay four pounds alfalfa six pounds
of corn grain and six pounds of wheat
mitts in other words we went from two
pounds of corn grain up to six pounds
our feed costs went up accordingly to a
dollar eighty but our feed cost per
pound a gain is now the lowest at five
ninety six
another action we have here is just a
dry ration of alfalfa hay and corn grain
13 pounds of alfalfa hay with seven
pounds of corn grain
gave us a 2.3 pounds per day gain 77
cost to gain a dollar 86 per day oh
that's getting kind of expensive well
now let's look at a ration that we don't
have much for grass hay or other feeds
we're just going to use alfalfa and corn
grain and when we're feeding that amount
of corn grain we have to provide an
additional protein supplement and a
bagged feed works quite well for that
3.2 pounds per day gain which has pushed
these calves along pretty good our cost
of gain is 6.96
at 69 cents which is uh competitive but
our costs per day are now 230. 230 2.23
cents again we're over three pounds a
day gain now if you want to increase
that gain a little bit higher and feed
less alfalfa and more corn grain
are at three and a half pounds per day
gain uh we're going to end up with our
two and a quarter per day feed cost
which is just a couple pennies more
for uh the 3.5 average daily gain versus
3.2 and our feed costs are the lowest of
six point at 64 cents per pound to gain
things to remember feet cost decreases
energy increases excuse me as the grain
uh
increases in the orac should say the
average daily gain of the rash of that
provides from the ration is increased
well okay now let's look at grass hay
with a little bit of distillers grains
to be added as protein and energy
now this is a 1.7 average daily gain
only it's the cheapest is a buck and a
half a day but our feed cost is at 82
cents
now if we put a little corn into that
ration at four pounds and take out some
of the hay we're going to get 2.8 pounds
per day gain
1.73 a day is what the cost is with a 61
61 cost gain
definitely workable but not our one of
our cheaper rations
if you want a little bit better gain at
3.4
uh we're using grasshay corn grain
distillers grains and limestone 3.4
average daily gain
find out this is one of our lowest cost
feed per cost to gain
and at a dollar 86 per day and that's
3.4 in the earlier slide we're at three
we're above threes and it was over two
two and a quarter a day for feed costs
so in this particular example you can
see that going from just a little bit of
corn grain up to a little bit more and
just changing the dynamics of the ration
really improved our feed conversion or
increased our average daily gain quite a
bit just a small difference of adding
three more pounds of corn grain and
taking out the grass hay and of course
we had to include limestone to increase
the calcium content of this ration
because this tillage grains is high in
in phosphorus and corn grain is high in
phosphorus as well
let me just make a few comments on rate
of gain goals
if we're looking for oil roll
ascending cattle to the grass market
making stockers out of these cattle
backgrounding them at less than two
pounds per day gain
that's what we call low rate of gain
medium rates again usually two to three
pounds
i like to call these as your grow cattle
without adding extra fat to them or
putting on condition they just have a
nice growth and frame once you go
brighter than three pounds per day
average day of the gain
if you do that more than 45 60 days
you're going to end up with
calves that add a little bit more flesh
to them
and when that happens you may reduce
subsequent feedlot performance and
cattle buyers know that so they will
discount accordingly however if you know
the genetics behind the cattle they can
do this type of game without any loss of
performance you need to know
what what you're buying and know this
best way to do that is know the
historical performance of cattle and go
that direction
if
you're going to feed cattle i always
encourage you to target the gain with a
balanced ration
said earlier as you increase the protein
and energy you get better feed
efficiency and better average daily
gains
so one of my examples here is to if you
want three pounds a day for 60 days
that'd be 180 pounds or we can do it a
different way and that is we want to get
a pound and a half day gain for 120 days
it really depends upon what your market
weight and date is going to be and how
you wish to feed cattle sometimes
there's changes in the market
that allow you to
uh
run cattle at a lower average daily gain
to pick up a higher price so even though
the feed costs might not be as efficient
the market gain will more than offset
that and provide an opportunity for you
and if this is all home raised feeds
then again the cost might be quite a bit
lower than it would be if it was
purchased out on the uh market just
opportunity cost would be uh what you'd
have to consider that
always like to have people think about
co-products and i talked about where
they're located in north dakota if you
need an info sheet of
where they're sourced at and prices and
phone calls to call please contact your
local county extension agent they should
have a list that i put together that
they can
provide to you that's your local account
extension agent in north dakota
if you can contract fees usually there's
summer lows that you can work around
anytime you have to haul at long
distances that really reduces your price
competitiveness
although this year with the
transportation assistance program that
might make a little bit of difference on
what your cost might be
usually we look at high fiber
high fiber and actually they're
good in protein as well when we
background cattle things like wheat meds
and distillers grains work quite well in
a background ration for adding a little
extra protein and since it's not starch
baits
they provide extra fiber in the ration
as well which can somewhat limit the
gain that we're looking for
always encourage you to do a great job
of feeding management that means feed
bunks that don't have too much feed left
in them but aren't empty as well provide
some bedding on cold days that'll make a
nice environment for calves we've got
research of the carrington research
extensions and other shows that does
affect your feed efficiency and marbling
in cattle uh depending upon how big
they've been then how their environment
is while they've been growing
clean water is always a must if you're
going to put calves on feed
please try to reduce the amount of moldy
feeds you have so that might discourage
intake
obviously healthy calves grow better
than sick calves
try to look at ration changes slowly use
step up ratchets as an example
be sure to balance the ration for the
weight gain for the weight and type of
cattle that you have
and of course like i said earlier
consider your rate of gain goals calves
that gain
3 pounds
per day gain
may not show any discount at the
marketplace while other groups of calves
might please consider the type of calf
when you're looking at your rate rating
goal
if you're trying to improve feed per
gain with cattle look at ionophores
that'll increase your income your
improvement that'll improve the feed
efficiency by five to seven percent uh
the omniforester mints and the bovita
the trade names
you can use implants do the same thing
five to seven percent unless you're
an increase in average daily gain and
your feeding feed efficiency will
improve seven to twelve percent
if you're not in a natural program
implants work well
and there are feed uh
additives like her medicine bovita
declinate chloride that can control
coccidiosis
so
if you've ever had coccydiosis outbreak
in a cow in a calf crop you'll certainly
want to avoid that at all costs because
that can certainly ruin your your growth
and feed to gain when you have a
coccidious outbreak and coccidiosis is a
stress related disease so coccidity are
always in cattle but when there's enough
stresses they can come pathogenic then
you end up with your bloody scar issue
or nervous coxy issues and of course
those can be real problems in a feed
yard
just like to summarize here that this
year we've got higher feed prices
it happens every year though but that's
higher average daily gains usually have
lower cost per pound of gain be sure to
consider what feeds you use
because there's lots of different
options out there and as i did earlier
on some of these examples some of these
feed costs are priced quite a bit lower
so sometimes a corn grain ration is not
your cheapest average daily gain or cost
per pound again
it might include a curl pro
a co-product
obviously co-products are high in
protein and fiber and can help
are a nice addition to a ration you
start feeding too much though you'll
have to make sure the ration is balanced
for calcium phosphorus just because the
high phosphorous loads
concentrations that are in co-products
and of course good management always
leads to great calf gain